Jose what the hell is that that villain
is the sony rowley a robotic mp3 player
/ egg alright so this is sony's a idea
of a joke right I mean look at this
first of all it's it's an mp3 player
fine but it's egg-shaped yeah and let's
examine mysterious control system when I
top the top wheel controls the track and
the bottom wheel controls the volume so
whichever way you turn it the top always
is the track changer and the bottom is
always the volume changes totally retake
this I mean this is like this is like
the ipod shuffle it has no screen yeah
so if you want to find a different song
all you have to do is like all you can
do is sort of page through the sentence
one by one one by one the one you like
there's no LCD to tell you and I mean
there's you can only put up to like 500
songs on this only two gigs two gigs for
a four-hundred-dollar mp3 player but he
advances and then it dances right yeah i
mean really i think this is so nice like
four hundred dollar answer to the 999
dancing flower that you can get at
walgreens i mean give me a break you
want a little dancing mp3 player yeah i
think you can really be positive about
and say like maybe something like this
could be cool in like 10 15 or 20 years
but this is just it's the beginning and
it's really you know probably the big my
biggest problem with it is that it
doesn't have audio out so you can't
listen to it like you can't plug in
headphones and while it does have a
bluetooth connectivity you can't get
like bluetooth headphones and listen to
your songs either why would you want
audio out on this thing I mean are you
gonna like put this in your pocket and
take it on the bus and listen to some
tunes I don't think so never put an egg
in your pocket you know I'll tell you
what I'm gonna do with this
okay Stephen what does this look like to
you I'm gonna go with something from
Star Wars okay this is actually a box
for a cell phone and it was not produced
on Tatooine no no no it actually
contains the news a palm treo this is
the palm treo pro and i actually like it
as a piece of hardware at first glance
the first time I laid eyes on it I
thought it was very attractive the
keypad seen you know fairly fairly you
know roomie everything was kind of
intuitively set up there really
concerned about how it looks so you'll
notice that the design lines are very
similar to the iphone so you're getting
real rounded black curves what they've
done with this is they've added these
extra hardware buttons yeah basically
shortcuts to basically circumvent all
the problems that exist in windows
mobile so it's this button right here
yep the left one is a basically a fully
customizable soft key on the other side
they've got a dedicated Wi-Fi button so
let's get to the not so positive yeah so
you know I have problem with it's the
half-ass touch screen the touch screen
was not really responsive and you needed
to make it really work right you needed
the stylus which is hard to find sure
does the stylist to actually scroll
through even the state using stylist was
not very responsive so it's five hundred
dollars palm treo pro how many blue
balls beak you would you give this guy
I'm kind of feeling 66 blue balls I'm
feeling a six okay so this is all
product just with a couple issues yeah
okay I'm stoked about it i think i'd
probably give it six blue balls as as
well i'm really excited about future
versions of the trio and hopefully when
the when the jesus trio comes out it'll
come out in a box it looks like a death
star or a millennium falcon something
like that